skip that are below ride a little over
hmm welcome everybody to my brand new
show season 1 season 2 season 3 all at
the same time we're trying it out never
done before the rule here is simple but
I will try and break them down for you
if you happen to laugh smile or grin
during this video you lose the challenge
if you happen to laugh smile or grin in
this video you also lose the challenge
by accepting this challenge smash like
on this video and by the G fuel with
code PD pi now it's only 10% now now I'm
already gonna lose it the first one
because I'm already seeing dammit stop
it zoella is literally Brent Brent from
the office who is this self loving and
how do I call it self loving and lacking
of insight but still trying to act
humble character and let's just watch me
because I'm just me know what I'm not
really interesting but obviously well
six million people think I am I'm not
really that interesting but you know six
million people probably think I am I am
pretty humble but also so good I love I
love her face as well it's so perfect
like mmm I'm just gonna say I'm not that
bad interesting it's kind of tiring all
the time youtubers have to be so uh no
it's not that big a deal you know what
she has accomplished is pretty amazing
and she has every right to brag about it
I think it's just those two sentences
probably didn't work the best together
and she probably sees that but it's
still hilarious next me that's not the
show Felix learn the rules check out my
health bar how is yours doing
[Music]
cool I'm rolling I'm rofl mowing
literally rofl bowing at that one that
was too hard
next clip what's that it wow this is
really hard
what is his snow Samar that made someone
grin someone lost a challenge in there
at least we saw people in the streets
ready to put 2018 in the rear view
mirror and say hello to 2019 we also saw
this dog with a banana ah oh my god is
that a dog with a banana
let's try random 2018 of the rear view
mirror and say hello to 2019 we also saw
this dog with a banana
god damn I need to my signboard dog with
the banana that's so epic
okay who is it gonna be oh boy
this has been a tough challenge so far
thank you for playing along it turns out
there's only five more contestants out
of 80 million this has to be one of the
hardest toughest ones so far
okay let's freakin get going guys yes
exit everyone lost children crying no
one can stand against the power of
children crying oh that's beautiful
oh poor child I'm sorry
oh that's beautiful
he didn't even look good to begin with
it's like what is that I don't think it
matters if that falls over I don't think
that's working Oh got more help looks
like I'm still in the game guy
[Music]
I thought it was gonna bring a dead s
phases well that's great Daniel moving
on yes I want a full version
I want the whole what is that super
movie called like unfriended or
something or is that a different version
that looks different doesn't it
looks like I'm losing you know some
people would say it's unfair that I
could just drink G fuel to replenish my
health but so can you okay it's not
exclusive to me just by the G fuel code
the pewdiepie and check it out yeah oh
oh my like a you can already see the
fake bind fake its fake
okay not funny fake fake and gay
the sad part about that joke is I'm
literally raywilliamjohnson at this
point baby changing station baby hanging
station finally they did it absolute man
let's next clip everyone
oh it's Annabelle
Jesus Christ is dragged out hi welcome
to Chili's
goddamnit I'm not even trying at this
point because I have G fuel I don't have
to anymore it's more like laughs as much
as you want challenge because I used to
code pretty pie to buy G fuel get a bowl
okay fill it with water put some pepper
and no water that's cool
put some dish soap on your finger the
reason this happens is because you're a
virgin
Oh did you just call himself a virgin I
don't think we need a scientific
experiment to know that you guys are
virgins thank you very much was he
actually playing Mario 64 was he
actually because this is me whenever I
die in Minecraft I don't know okay Jesus
Christ what an epic freakout even know
how to play that thing nope
but I'll never know until I try
[Music]
they actually said to me Cooper's on
their toes oh I'm so curious is that a
real commercial I like that
give it a 10 it gets a tip we find it
the best clip of all time
oh yes papa someone sends me this in the
mail papa it's a ring for six Popov I
know what the first who talks like that
how can you talk with such a strong
Swedish accent pathetic learn how to
properly pronounce your words and normal
a collection Oh literally open store not
if you are liking it right now oh my god
literally almost forgot hello no stop it
speaking of James Charles by the way
James Charles called sneaks subscribers
sisters I've been calling my subscribers
for many years broke and I realize now
I've been tapping out half the market
I've only appealed to one gender how
discriminatory of me the
I think everyone go tell James Charles
Rose invites sister's to subscribe to
PewDiePie I watched intellect commercial
and I've learned to do better now
so now Bruce will help out sisters so
sisters can subscribe subscribe to
pewdiepie sis scribe to pewdiepie do you
want to see me die from t-series cuz
that's what's gonna happen
you don't want pretty pipe to die do you
I don't have infinite G fuel you know
sis sky the blue any pie smash like and
subscribe in this video fired by the
merch it's available for a couple more
days
thank you